- She started screamcacacacacac.
(rires)
♪ ♪ ♪
conjurer les drames vécus.
(r)))
Derrière la joie des
retrouvailles se cacpipipipipip.
SAHRAA KARIMI
- L'ambassade du Canada m'a
assuré que j'étais admissible
que j'avais travaillé pour eux.
- Sahraa Karimi est Afghane.
Elle a fui Kaboul il y a 8 mois
et, depuis, elle attend
à sa demande de réfugié.
(rires)
Cette cinéaste de renommée
internationale est la première t
du film afghan.
Elle profite de l'hospitalité
de son amie aux Étadededededede,
avec tout ce que les femmes
peuvent en
une société patriarcale...
et qui ne respecte pas
les femmes autonomes.
- "Nous sommd'd'd'd'd'd'd'd'd'dz
une situation difficile."
- Son découragement est visible.
- "Prenez note que votre demande
- Comme ininininines
de milliers d'Afghans,
elle se heurte à la lenteud'd'd.
Mais le temps est un luxe
qu'elle ne peut s'offrir.
- J'ai travaillé pour eux, maist
des préoccupations quant
à mon admissiPrPrPrPrPrPrPrPrPr,
mes nièces n'ont pas été
à l'école depuis presque un an.
- Son frère et ses nièces
canadiens en Ukraine.La guerre .
- "Nous encourageons
votr
toutes les mesures légales
qu'elle juge nécessa
en dehors de cette demande."
pas question pour elle
de dirananananananada en fait
plus pour les Ukrainiens
que pour les Afghans.- Les Ukrat
toute l'aide qu'on leur offre,
mais l
Mon président a fui le pays.
Par contre, le jeune président
là-bas et, chaque jour,
il prouve au monde entier
qu'il défend son pays.
♪ ♪ ♪
À 36 ans, elle fait partie
de cette jeunesse afghane
américaine, dont elle gardeun as
années aura été l'avènement
d'une nouvelle génération
d'Afghans. Des milliers
les écoles et les universités;
nous ptitititititititivement
à la société. Mais la communauté
internationale et les s s s s s.
Ils ont cru des seigneurs
de guerre et des politiciens
corrompus.
- Pendant que la coalition
à maintenir le fragile équilibre
politique en........
Sahraaààààààààààààààààààààààààà,
de sauvegarder un outil
essentiel à la survie du pays :
la culture.
des plans quinquennaux pour
encourager les jeunes cinéastes
indépendants à faire des films.
lililililililililité
pour une représentation
internationale d
- Elle a pu compter sur
le soutien de son ancien
de la Culture, lui-même
en exil à Washington.
De l'ardeur au travail
et une franchise qui
ont bousculé les codes.
Elle a travaillé
sur un documatatatatatatatatatas
financé par le Canada.
- Il s'agissait
d'un documentaire
de la santé de la femme.♪♪♪♪♪♪♪♪
- Mais ses liens avec le Canada
sa mère et sa soeur y vivent.
- J'ai beaucoup de liens
je collabore à un film canadiene
- On a besoin de
femmes comenenenenenenenenenener
notre cinématographie,
pour sortir un peu des murs
du Québec et du Canada.
- Les deux artistes
sur le long métrage canadien
- Une tr'e'e'e'e'e'e'e'e'e'e'e'e
qui a un doctorat, c'est
une femme qui est éduquée,
c'est une femme qui peut
d'ici avec son propre métier.
- Lorsqu'on lui parle du statut
elle ressent la même
incompréhension.
- C'est plus que long, là,
c'est une descente aux enfers
ces hommes-là qui sont
éparpièèèèèèèèèèèèète,
qui ont... qui ont pas de job,
qui ont pas d'argent, ssssssssss
pour pouvoir venir au Canada.
♪ ♪ ♪aaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaan
en maison, de ville en
18 capitales et autant
de festivals de cinéma,
qui l'ont accueillie.isisisisisé
en Afghanistan.
J'ai f p p p p p p p p p p p p .
J'ai perdu mon contact
avec les miens,
j'ai perdu mon inspiration,
continuer à y croire.CeCeCeCeCen
d'une nouvelle terre d'accueil,o